I have zero desire to become famous for
the sake of being famous like none
there's actually just a lot of costs
with that what I wanted was business
owners and so we tested out actually the
last 90 days lead so leading up to two
weeks ago I made almost exclusively very
wide content so it was like relationship
stuff we made uh Fitness stuff like food
you know food video we made um like you
know advice to my younger self like
things like that and so we got more
overall views but in terms of throughput
of from those views to high quality like
applications into the business or just
even Book Sales which I use as like kind
of a a looser metric for quality of of
eyeballs went way down and so we have
completely like so one of the big shifts
I'm doing is I'm basically making almost
exclusively business content now so I
mean like I have no marriage to anything
like if relationship videos is what
would generated the most business owners
because there's this theory in the in
the content world that like so there's
there's two theories that I at least the
data that we looked at just completely
didn't agree with which was one is that
shorts viewers become Longs viewers and
I just haven't seen that like I hear it
all the time but when I looked at it
that just wasn't the case people who
watch Longs want more Longs people want
shorts watch more shorts caveat if you
find me in shorts in one platform but
you're a YouTube's long viewer then you
might watch my YouTube Long View like uh
content and so but it's like if you only
watch YouTube shorts you're not going to
become a Longs viewer you will just keep
watching whatever you normally consume
so people have consumption preferences
by platform and so I kind of see them as
they're like in separate tracks in terms
of bringing people in for the CTA like
the give to ask ratio right um as soon
as you start running ads in my opinion
everything becomes gives and then the
ads do all the asking for you which will
help you out as a content creator
because then it's like I'm just trying
to push as much value as I possibly can
in shorts I do Zero ctas Store wories um
I do think is appropriate for ctas I
don't think it hurts your reach and so
if you do like one one or two of those a
week I don't think that's going to hurt
anything um Longs I see as somewhat
different in that it depends on the CTA
and so if I was like like I see me
providing free stuff as also gives and
so me having a CTA for free stuff I
don't see as a take from the audience
and so the reason that I have the like
the books for example that are free on
the
and free on my podcast and whatnot is so
that it's it's like it's free you can
have it if you want to and if there's
alternative formats where they can do it
like for a fee then that's because of
their consumption preference but if
you're broke then use use whatever and
so the the tldr of this is that I think
you can absolutely have ctas in content
um that drive to stuff that's as long as
it's relevant and how you integrate it I
think it actually works fine so like my
number one YouTube video across my whole
channel has a 14-minute CTA at the end
number one video what what what do you
define as your CTA though because I
think CTA some people have this
perception that it's like go do this now
click my link but what is what does a
CTA mean for you so I say if you're a
business owner who's trying to scale
I've got books and courses that you can
check out acquisition. comom if you're
someone who's you know trying to start a
business or get started I put all these
resources together for you and you can
start you know you can start on school
and so I just do that so you just point
them towards your free stuff not even
just to buy yeah just for my organic now
ads then turn around and just
scoop so like by they're I mean all ads
are ctas so like that's that's how I
basically you you chunk up a level and
then you think about the give ask ratio
across everything people see and so ads
now take up a percentage of what people
are going to see in the marketplace and
so I have to compensate for that ask
with give does that make sense now the
gives that I have I still have ctas for
free stuff so they can still you know
join Thea list and they still might buy
books or whatever it is but that's that
that's been the evolution of now that we
run ads with school I was like okay I
have to I have to compensate for that
you've seen homos ads right you want to
win
$1,000 I'm giving it to you for
free I want $1,000 that's how they scoop
up right like you you've engaged with
something of hosi so the ads follow yeah
yeah so I see the purpose of organic as
getting free free facial recognition and
ideally like at the coldest edges of
this it's how many people recognize my
face that in and of itself is going to
create higher ctrs higher conversion
rates and at higher prices one level
underneath of that is people who
recognize my face and have gotten some
sort of positive experience with the
content that I had even if it was just
one video they're like you know I did
like that video that guy made cool like
the next level is like they also know my
name you know what I mean and then
believe that is like oh I watch a lot of
his stuff like all the time and I'm a
regular viewer right so there's there's
these Circles of awareness and so the
purpose of content as I see it is like
shorts absolutely have Roi just way more
with ads than they do with like trying
trying to take a short and then like
provide value and have CTA really tough
yeah yeah really really tough and so I
don't even do it because I throw in you
can't I don't even mention the community
my in my shorts I'll just like talk
about a relevant um subject in that's
involved in the community then then I'll
be like like a meals video I do a
grocery Hall if you want recipes for
these meals in like the last 3 seconds
it's only 5% of the people who watch the
video all the way through get to there
but the conversion still pretty good I
me personally just cuz like this how I
think I put it in the in the description
and I put as like first comment and I
and I have it in profile and so I kind
of see it as like if someone wants to
take the next step they'll they'll
immediately be able to do that and that
way like I might get 10 times the views
by not having three or four more seconds
where people want to dip does that make
sense so that's that's the trade that I
make in terms of short content um in
terms of what we do on Instagram we just
do reals right now um for for the most
part because they just get the most
views in terms of new audience I do see
like a picture on Instagram as like an
email now so if you've ever seen it like
you'll get way more likes and way more
like and you'll almost like I at least
for me I get like guaranteed reach but
it goes to No One new and so it's like
if you there's a picture of me or doing
something whatever or Carousel I'll I I
basically almost like Guarantee Way
higher reach just within people who know
who I am and so I think those are like
you mark it with the reals and what the
platform is saying like this is what
we're going to show to new people right
now but then I make you could make your
kind of like ctas with the um with the
images does that make sense so it's like
nurturing through the like pictures more
nurture your audience is that why you do
your um your Tweet as reals
like yeah yeah they bang too they're
really good yeah they Crush yeah super
high Lage one thing we've seen a lot of
f success with on um organic CTA is like
if you have to do if you can't run Fay
outs but you also need CT to make money
is instead of offering more like instead
of here's this one recipe if you want
more go to my school group offer custom
so like I can make custom recipes based
on your Macros because like if you're on
organic there's an infinite amount of
more content like they you just keep
scrolling but to get custom they have to
go through your thing and if you offer
like one-on-one coaching or a group
coaching or whatever like that's their
option to get C to at school cuz you
over more is overuse like everyone says
you can get
more really good so how do you give
something custom to each member if you
really want to scale like thousand plus
members group calls small groups is
good just split that
Up Customs
good how how close does your content
need to actually be to the people that
you're trying to find so if you're
trying to find business owners and now
you're going Broad and now you guys all
talk about going like you're doing load
of different things if you're just
trying to find like I sto that's the
point of me doing that 90-day test is
I'm not doing that anymore yeah so if if
now you you now you know what you know
if you had to go back in time to find
businesses only businesses to get them
onto school to build a platform in
school how would you do that you make
business content and business adjacent
content so I see like I see personal
development as like one step below but
still adjacent like Rel like
productivity stuff I see is adjacent to
business I see like time man well time
management is kind of like productivity
like things like that I see as both wide
but still semi- relevant to the audience
um but the idea that like I do a
relationship video and then business
owners also have relation like it's it's
too many steps to get the right people
because it's really just people who
consume relationship
stuff just want more relationship stuff
which I have no desire to make the the
thing is what I struggle with the most
and obviously everyone here probably
doesn't because you've gone through is
like that that first kind of step to
start when you like who am I who's this
guy like why is he talking to me like so
when you click on a profile that has
zero followers and zero views like is it
just the content that you're saying the
words need to carry your profile that's
the only thing that's going to build
that trust with you and the client to
get them over to fill out a form it's
just evidence it's just so how would you
use sorry how do you use someone that
has business experience and background
with results to then showcase that to
get them that you use that in the
profile to edify who you are doesn't
come across the arant and like so
there's I mean there's different like
one of our Big Marketing laws my team
can tell you is State the facts and tell
the truth just like it's just like
that's the big bold thing and underneath
of that it's say what no one else can
say and show what no one else can show
from a marketing perspective and I do
that in ads I do that in content it's
like one time State the facts and tell
the truth say what no one else can say
show what no one else can show because
there's always things that you have
unique to your brand that only you can
show a lot of people just don't show it
and there's things that you can say that
no one else is saying so your your
unique your unique setting proposition
no not even this is just for just just
for proving who I am right so it's like
even even when I had like like to your
point like how's it like you see me now
but like when I started in the gym space
I was a very very small fish and there
was like very established players who
were like jimm Gus who were all older
than me who all like were just older
than me just put it that way right
they're all way older and so I just had
to overcompensate by just being so much
better than they were in terms of the
that I was putting out and I was like
this is a model that everyone's teaching
here's my model mine makes more money I
was like it doesn't matter if he's been
here forever I was like these gyms I'll
compete these
gyms I feel like the only thing that
I've got I I I feel like this platform
like just has this massive like
opportunity for businesses agencies like
what I've done for me but I feel like no
one else is doing that so now I finally
have something I feel like could bring
to social media to Showcase to be look I
did this for myself with no following
you can too bring that P
yeah I mean you put the proof so as far
as I'm concerned the content serves the
audience as the give if they're curious
for more they will then click your
profile which is what most people do if
you see something new you click over
like at least for me that's almost
always what I'll do if I see something
interesting and then the profile tell me
in one snippet who this person is and
why I should listen to
them and then you have your your link or
your DM or your you know whatever your
CTA is that's in their profile and again
you can put that as the first comment
you can put it in the description like
you have three different places you can
put the CTA outside of the actual
content itself that I think will carry
the content a lot further in my opinion
I think I think one thing as well that
you mentioned where it's like say what
no one else is saying I feel like that
for me at first was something that was
very overwhelming because like I'm
talking about wellness and and eating
healthy and fitness which is the most
saturated information on the internet
and so in my head I was like okay it's
going to be kind of hard to not say what
iOS is saying but how can I say it
differently right and so I think with
whatever you're doing is like you want
to be able to explain things in the most
digestible form imp possible um that
that at least is something that's helped
me a lot so I speed faster than normal
just to like uh you know keep people
engaged and stuff like that I'd really
try and dump things
down did you just find ways to like
distinguish or like how did you you know
create that separation between that
saturation um so before I was making
Finance content I had like this one day
I just had an epiphany I was like dude
like how can you turn people's heads
like these like you need to like I mean
unless you're like extremely
professional know what you're talking
about like you need to be able to turn
people doesn't make them listen to you
and then I was just's like dude I'm
going to start speaking faster like
really bringing the enthusiasm and
passion and big shift is how to to how I
I say this a lot but it people still
don't do it like if you say like how to
three ways to blah blah blah kind of
sucks like everyone says it like the
amount of people's profiles that I see
that have like five followers that are
like six neat tricks that just like no
one gives a [__] right it's six ways I
helped this person do something or six
ways I because the thing is is like how
is it unique well there's only one of
you and you have the clients that you've
worked with like my case study stuff are
videos that I make I'm like no one else
can make this
content yeah I've noticed that too I
noticed in in the school games it's like
opinion pieces versus like a story about
something that happened right like the
worst thing I hate it when I see someone
do a post and it's like how to be
successful six things I look at their
profile they've got one member in their
group which is them yeah
and they haven't even commented on
anyone's stuff so I'm like shut up
basically like in my mind
um but then you see Evelyn for example
say I over the last 30 days I spent this
much money on a and here's what I found
and she just lays out the
facts that's the difference right it's
state the facts and tell the truth cu no
one's doing anything everyone's just
talking [__] on the internet so so if
you don't have evidence so this is for
everybody who's listening who's back
home so the best version of this is like
you know I I helped all these people
just like you do this thing one degree
below that is like I did this thing that
you also want to do and you just are
like me and so you want the same thing a
version before that is I did this work
that you're not willing to do and so I
will show you the result of that work
and so I could just as easily have a
title for the YouTube video that I have
for the the six big shifts that we're
making our content as like I got eight
million people across these platforms
like over the last 3 years this what I
learned if I didn't have the proof from
the 8 million I could just say I made
35,000 posts this is what like I'd be
like well [__] I mean he probably
learned something you know what I mean
and so like that is the edification and
so like the action creates the proof are
the people at home that don't want to do
the actual hard thing like they're not
the expert they don't want to do the
actual art thing you can make an
observation of like how someone else did
the heart thing and like back into their
process and then it's even unbelievable
because like ideally you're doing it
about a big person who's like really
successful and the metrics are easy to
to prove and you're just like connecting
the dots for the audience yeah when I
started my channel I had no credibility
so I talked about stoicism and what
Marcus Rus said it's like no one cares
what I say but people care what he said
because he has The credibility super
strong yeah with education content
everyone wants a deal on time so if you
think about fundamental what education
is it's like I spent this time learning
math and I'm going to teach it to you in
less time than it took me to learn it
and so people were like wow I don't want
to do all those 10,000 problems show me
the three-step way that you do it from
this big thing you did and so I mean I
think this how civilization moves
forward is that like it takes us all
this time to learn this thing we then
distill it down someone starts one step
further and then like that's how you put
a brick in the wall and so like if we
are quote Educators which almost
everybody here is I think is anyone here
an Entertainer no okay so if everybody
here's an educator then all we want to
demonstrate is huge Roi on time for them
and so the more time you can show the
more cost you can show so Evelyn did
both she's like I spent all this time
making these ads and I spent all this
money doing it and it's like well wow I
don't have to spend that time or that
money and I can get the same lesson this
is a good deal and then they they listen
they buy and then they they follow her
whatever that that was definitely one of
my biggest takeaways in the last three
years of making content in the beginning
um cherry-picking facts and not wasting
a damn second of anyone's time and just
delivering the value as quick as
possible is the only way is the fastest
way to build that initial audience
because once people know who you are
then you can kind of fluff it up a
little bit more because they going to
listen unconsciously but I mean like you
were saying before in the beginning that
portfolio that Garden of content that
you're building in the beginning it's
just straight delivery cherry picking
and in my theory is that you keep doing
that and actually don't get fluffy well
I yeah that's like this is what we saw
in our stuff you can because you have a
because you have an audience right and
so the idea though is if I like
if by percent I I grew the most when I
treated everyone like they didn't know
who I was and I had to earn every single
second it's continu like the guy who
dates his wife like it's at the first
date on the on their 10 years keeps the
wife right the one who keeps the
audience is the one who treats them like
they don't know who he is and he has to
keep earning it every day and so like
one of the six shifts that we have from
the 35,000 pieces of content we put out
is that we are no longer doing basically
what I would consider branded content
meaning the basically like Al Mo's diet
Alex Mo's version of branding because if
you don't know who I am who gives a [__]
and if the point of me making content is
to get more people to find out about me
then I have to not say who I am I have
to say what I've done and then that
becomes the reference point for the
content just as something I mean do
whatever you want but that's what I'm
doing so first off I'll open up to you
guys what's been working well for you
right now um in terms of getting members
of school off organic man chat what was
it man chat many chat so running so you
post and and then have a Min chat link
and then yeah just have them comment and
then a man chat will automatically BM
them the link to join so comment CCA is
this on
Instagram yeah I've heard many people
using this successfully Yeah we actually
have a funnel buildout so instead of
sending them straight to school cuz some
people can't really articulate it they
just see SCH so s to a funnel yeah it
just warms them up you can send them
like a lead magnet like something free
for example I've made this free guide
for you uh as well while they see the
free value they at the bottom there'll
be like the vsl there um the the sales
that are there then like oh wow he
really helped me so I'll I'll join the
things so it warms them up for the
school he maybe we should really cuz I
know this works well maybe we should
really flash this out it does really
work so first of all you got to have an
Instagram page with a following right
and then
you post you do a post what do you
saying your what does this post look
like so we do we do direct DM um CTA is
like send us a key word you can also do
a comment I haven't done the comment
before but it's been the most effective
strategy CU you can pre- automate voice
messages and and then at the end bring
in the virtual sales letter which is the
offer so but what is the actual post so
basically it's like it's like you giving
free value at the start here's how to
lose weight in three different ways and
then you say the free value after that
You' be like I've actually made a full
guide if you want more on this so
because you really giv them value you
say DM me uh fat loss um many chat will
see that and they will send that over to
their DM so when something's sent over
to DM it's more warm because it seems
like we sent it so when you do that
they're like wow this guy messaged me
they'll click it and they'll consume the
free guide uh allowing them to be more
warm to get into your
program so you use the call me and
Trigger so we I do if if I'm on live and
they comment certain way my live they'll
get s a DM if they comment a certain
word on my post even if they can spell
it well oh so you get on the live too
get a ton of I'll bet you get a ton
during the live yeah during the live and
then also if they send me a DM um
they'll get it so one of the I just had
one of my first posts that just went
viral um I actually learned this from
Jose where I'll start the post off with
a hook so the first thing I said was um
this is what I do if I had less than
$100 in my name and I wanted to make 10
or $20,000 and so that right there just
grabbed people's attention and then just
throughout the post it was like maybe a
one minute or less post I just gave a
free like game on step by step do this
that there made it real simple you want
more information about this comment the
word deals under this post and I'm going
to DM you a link to my community and
then they'll get set to our funnel we
get their um phone number we get their
email address we get their name so even
if they don't sign for the school
Community we have their contact
information so now getting text messages
or getting emails so we're just C some
marketing to them so you lead capture
and then it's a school on the thank you
page like a school like redirects after
you after they opt in exactly they'll
opt in and then it'll take them to a
second page and then they just it'll
collect the payment and then that'll
send it over to the school okay got it
understood to add on to what Rashida
said with the like Instagram lives and
Tik Tok lives what you can do is you can
automate the live as well so what we did
to actually really get oursel in this
position is to go live literally twice
to three times a day and yeah and what
we did was um we've give out profile
reviews so we're basically help people
grow their social media so we sent we
told them comment down um in the live um
guide and they will like get sent the
school so we did profile like reviews so
we're like holding their profile up and
reviewing it giving them like
personalized value and people would be
like wow I want that and so if you want
a full review hop over to my school we
have group calls like this every single
week imagine if I gave you this every
single week right and speaking actually
one-on-one with you and you can run that
automation through through live as
well I like that a lot so either a
comment CTA which you can do on lives I
feel I mean me just shooting from the
hip here if you're live with a lot of
people and you're saying comment this if
you want it you're going to get a ton of
comments right and then all of them get
shot over to to Min chat and then they
get either the lead magnet which was
your method or for your method you just
send them straight to the funnel to opt
in and then go to the school Community
after they collect you collect a payment
the cool one about the comment is it
probably boosts the reach of the post
because as soon as they on it then it'll
automatically have me send a comment
comment under their post and check your
BM and it's a lower friction thing than
sending a DM I think yeah yeah have you
tasted the comment one we haven't done
the comment one yet that would be
interesting yeah the follow-up comment's
a nice little nugget too cuz then you
get you get double the comment what's
the follow-up comment I missed that so
yeah go ahead it'll just little comment
where it GS and then it'll leave a
follow I saying I just sent you a DM or
check a DM buy yeah like in like you can
say like in five minutes like if they've
seen it in like 10 minutes they'll
follow up hey bro how'd you go with the
link or hey bro how' you go with this
yeah so then it like allows them to
follow up yeah so check your DM comment
you send the DM and then if they haven't
responded yet 5 minutes later it's like
hey did you like it or exactly
exactly yeah yeah yeah and you just set
like a a string like a t like a board
and he just goes yeah it's it's quite
seamless anyone else have any other
strategies they did organic yeah go for
yeah so me just pulling out my camera
and just recording like just very
non-edited raw content for so I don't
understand it it's working very well to
shorts a day um I used to do a long
videos that's how like started and this
is doing better and just posting those
same reals on every single social media
is it's just doing everything I don't
know why I believe it I posted a raw
uncut one the other day and it's done
very very well I know yeah Raw and Uncut
it's just fa anyways so the M way we
grow are we just talking about social
media cuz we do have another or the main
way we grow our community is through
free webinars yeah so we do weekly
webinars every week you email your list
say do you email your list how do you
get people to the webinar yeah fre we'll
send out emails send out text messages
promote it on social media my business
partner has a huge Vol way um so we'll
do weekly webinars and then at the end
of the webinar we offer them a bonus if
they join our community so at the end of
the webinar we're upselling into I 3 to
5 day boot camp usually those boot camps
or a few hundred but now we're telling
them if you buy a ticket to enter into
our school Community you'll get you'll
get a free ticket to the uh the boot
camp and so that's the biggest way that
we can grow on a community that's in the
most
successful so the bonus is the free
ticket bonus for joining School joining
school and then you get a free ticket to
the 5-day boo camp and the 5-day boot
camp is really sell upselling them to a
high ticket mentorship but for those who
aren't in position for the high ticket
we can still keep them in the low ticket
in the school and it we're just
nurturing them so they ready for a high
ticket so free virtual event which is
the webinar and then from there join my
school and if you do that you can attend
this other event that normally you'd
have to pay for but it's also free is
that one virtual too yeah it's virtual
so um the webinar is we're selling the
boot camp okay so yeah we're selling the
boot camp and then okay you get free
access if you join a school community so
you do the whole pitch of selling the
boot camp and say you could pay for it
or just join cost one of my favorite
pitch strategies yeah so that's that's
been success love that so did you
already have that boot camp established
before you launch your school we did but
surprisingly a lot of people haven't
really don't go about it the b c is
valuable like we just give them so we
pack so much information in those five
days so that they don't want to miss
that boot can we just make sure that we
make sure yes a five so so do you pay
for the like you pay for the like like
the place where they stay or it's
virtual it's a 5ay virtual boot camp oh
gotta how's it how's it built out on
your school is it just like a couple
different sections of the modules saying
boot camp part one boot camp part two or
um we just put the link on the calendar
we just have the in fo the Z links on
the cabin so you have to be in the
school Community to access the boot can
also it's interaction in col or pay
$10,000 which
they and then everybody that's already
in the school Community have access to
every Bo Camp every month cuz again we
shy it up sste of high tiet so you hold
one five day boot camp every month three
to five days yeah and so that's a huge
part of the delivery from the school
perspective is that they get do they
only get one or they just get that free
boot camp every time as long as they're
in a community they can attend every how
do you get 450 posts out in two days
worth of effort like what's your
process where's my
guys work um a lot of work I
mean is it like writing to like then
shooting the big the biggest secret
secret weapon that I have is Twitter or
X whatever um that's actually like no
one no one knows that but like
everything is so I just I tweet all day
long on X and then the stuff that does
well we then use the crap out of so that
then obviously gets me people on X I
take that that turns into Instagram
reals from there I will read the
Instagram reals that I know perform into
a camera and then those become clips
that also Crush literally different
format for the same thing and then I'll
take 20 of those and string them
together and make them a YouTube
video and then when we caption all of
the posts that we do we use other high
performing tweets to caption the other
tweets like my captions are just two
tweets it's tweet one which is the real
tweet two which is the caption is just
another tweet cuz I so if you ever see
anything written from acquisition. me I
wrote it everything it's just all on my
Twitter and so they'll search like
friendship loyalty sales whatever and
there's you know 50 tweets about it and
they'll just grab one that goes you know
as closest with the tweet that they made
for the real and that becomes that so
you just like get inspired twe yeah and
then you just take the best one yeah I
wouldn't even say inspired there's just
like stuff happens and I'd be like don't
do rev shares for Equity like don't do
advice for it does not work unless
you're doing minuscule amounts and even
then people hate you that's super
interesting she used Twitter as the
smallest friction just proof of concept
whatever tweets do the best you use
those to create reels generate a
question from that and then you bulk
those for the bigger higher value
YouTube videos and there's zero penalty
for tweeting a lot the platform is BU
for it so so what so if you had uh let's
say you were to start your Twitter
account from zero like how I start from
zero yeah yeah yeah like uh let's say
right now you basically had zero
followers zero no one knows that your
power towards your value towards
scripting how would you start a Twitter
account and would you even start a
Twitter account if you already have
Instagram 100% I it's literally the core
of everything I do so yes I'm a so which
so I'm a writer first people don't know
this like the reason the books do well
is like I write them like no one else
writes I don't a ghost writer I write
them that's why they're good um and so
well I'll say this the reason they still
sell two years later is cuz they're good
like if I had had a ghost writer I could
sell a million copies on one day because
people will buy something that's
associated with me but not necessarily
they won't tell their friends about it
and that's what I I want the long tail
um so from uh if ICI had to start over
from Twitter I would have two proof
points that I try so one is going to be
in the description which is like who I
am what have I done now if you've done
nothing then everything has to be around
documenting stuff that you've that
you're actively working on like the the
person who's like here's how to like get
yourself to be motivated it's like dude
you have three or like I hate this it's
like I help people grow their their
Instagram followings and they have like
79 followers I'm like what are you doing
you don't pass the first check of proof
it's just OD like duh you have a Vegas
sign that just says like [__]
description and then because of the way
Twitter works you can pin one tweet and
so that tweet what I would have is a
long tweet that's like here's Who I Am
by the
way and then the tweets everything after
that is going to be consumed within that
context do you guys database your tweets
in anyway for rafson or that just search
you can sear I mean it's searchable
already as is
there's a Chrome extension called tweet
Hunter yeah or there's Twitter Advanced
SE do all that stuff I don't even use
any I literally like I only have one
thing that I use that just allows me to
schedule tweets out cuz sometimes I'll
think of like three or four and I'll
just like o well I'm not going to do
them in a row so I'll just space them
out a couple hours that's how I do it
and the clips where do you post the
clips the like you said you do the reals
and then you just re-shoot a clip so we
do we do different so our content is
different across YouTube shorts you
don't need to do this we do this it's
different on all platforms and so
YouTube shorts Instagram short uh reals
uh Tik Tok are the three short form
platforms that we're on right now and so
that's what we do and then we have a
couple uh Longs per week to go out on
YouTube uh I do podcasts as well which a
lot of the audio from YouTube turns into
podcasts um and yeah that's like that's
the content system we just do like five
or seven YouTube shorts a day I do I
tweet like five to seven times a day we
post just this is just my account we do
two or three um Instagram reels a day I
think we do like four Tik toks a day and
then we have whatever one I'm missing
that one has it too and then I have
Leila so times two what's the why do you
guys have a different strategy for what
you post on Instagram or what you post
on Tik Tok because Instagram penalizes
you you can't it doesn't like if I post
it 11 times we wouldn't get the same we
we we I mean I'm happy to do volume um
but no we saw two two to three was where
we kind of max out that's what most
people don't realize like you can't
can't span Instagram cannot yeah it
still functions more like a u like an
email list still compared to like
Twitter and Tik Tok which are Tik toks
actually move more in the Instagram
Direction but um where your stuff gets
shown to followers even if it's not as
good of content um but the original Tik
Tok was like anyone could go viral
because they just prioritized the
quality of the content and and basically
followers had zero influence on who saw
your stuff and I think I think just
based on what I'm saying it's it's
shifting a little bit more towards like
some like they will put your stuff
towards some followers do you ever I
mean I'm sure you do you AB test let's
say one tweet does well um you shoot you
say it one certain way for reals and
then a different way for YouTube shorts
or 100% we remix and repurpose as much
as we can so same topic different
different structure if we see if we see
that a tweet really well that I know
that that topic is interesting to people
or at least that phrasing is interesting
to people and so I'll say direct to
camera it'll go into an email it'll be a
caption on a different platform like we
use the crap out of it like tweets are
my my home base that's where that's
that's the actual only direct content
that I make everything else is
Multiplied from there do you have a plan
to repost the same exact content over a
long enough time horizon or do you yeah
like Greatest Hits Greatest Hits yeah
I'm fine with Greatest Hits we actually
think we do a bad job of doing it right
now I would like something I was like
hey we should you know maybe post this
stuff again um but yeah that's that's
actually something that we're working on
but up to this point it's been almost
entirely denovo yeah so recycling like
your top 10% of content and then just
sprinkling that back out even once or
twice a week you're greatest hits from a
year ago because you have new followers
to them it's not it's
new how how long in advance would you
post that for example I made a piece of
content that banged um depends on the
platform
so I can take something that was a tweet
from 6 months ago and I could do it
again today and it'll crush the same if
I think I think basically the more like
Instagram I think has the longest the
longest memory and the least amount that
you can post per day um like YouTube you
just can't do it at all like you can't
repost a video because the videos kind
of live forever so like I guess YouTube
would be the extreme on this on this
side and then Twitter is probably the
shortest shortest memory most forgiving
um in terms of volume and reuse TI Tok
kind I say Tik tok's like here yeah
exactly so the amount of time that you
that elapses between reusing the same
thing I think it also depends on how
fast you're growing I think your
definition of repurposing is like like
sometimes re-shooting as well right and
not just reposting yeah so do you just
have two or do you have more forms of
reposting sorry repurposing those are
the I mean crossplatform
different format and then literally just
redoing the same thing and just posting
an old clip again it's like four
different ways you can remix the same
thing YouTube's content ID system was
really really good because they check
the copyright they've got those
processes built out you can't repost
like doesn't work how long did you go
from just you independently doing your
content before you brought in the whole
team and stuff because I like my screen
time is just outrageous like between
shooting on for reals take talks YouTube
shorts and long form YouTube I thought
about adding Twitter last week but like
at this point it's like I need to out
how many how many hours do are you
getting I'm curious like nine nine every
day and I was in school so it was like
all day it's just like stimulation and S
yeah [__] no I uh I immed so if you've
read the leads book I talk about
agencies there's a chapter on agencies I
that's the strategy I use so day one I
had agencies for everything for Content
creation and then I told them day one
like my goal is to bring this in house
over time and so I'm going to learn
whatever I can and a lot of those guys
like they don't know as much as I know
now but they knew more than I did then
and so I just learned what I could way
faster and just like try I avoid like a
lot of new new be mistakes and then I
just make intermediary mistakes and just
had to learn how to like not make those
you know what I mean um but yeah a lot
of for me though like Capital wasn't an
issue and so it was just like I'm
willing to pay to just almost like be
accountable to making three YouTube
videos a week or whatever it was yeah
and then they would like trim them cut
them put a pack you know put the the
headline and the thumbnail on it which I
hated half the time and I was just like
whatever we'll deal with it
later I know along that same line do you
ever do you ever get tited like I mean
like never I've been slept since the 90s
it's so much Belling for so long
consistent like do you ever feel like I
think it's just as long as you talk
about stuff that you like and so my team
knows this and like there're some
sometimes they're really good about it
and I think setting that precedent with
the team is like hey I need you to come
with like 10 cool video ideas and like
honestly half the time I'm like cool I
don't want to do do any of those uh I
want to talk about this cuz it's top of
mind and so I I talk about the stuff
that I want to talk about and I think so
that also just kind of gives natural
like kind of variety to the content in
general because I'll be like really
focused on LTV stuff for a while um and
I'll be like you know what like I'll get
into like there's a sales issue for one
of the companies and like I'll just kind
of like rewash myself into sales stuff
and I get in sales mode and I talk about
sales and all my content for a little
bit and so I just kind of let that
happen naturally rather than if you're
like I have to do one thing on family I
have to do one thing like I have we have
never had content buckets ever if
content buckets happen it's because they
have occurred more than because we
planned them um which you you had the
observation point this total side note
the amount of like Alex rosi breakdowns
that are just completely false I find
hilarious um I'm like oh is that my four
pillars I don't do any of that um and so
no it's way more I talk about stuff that
I enjoy talking about and from a
constant strategy perspective I had this
roommate brilliant one of the two
smartest people I've ever met in my life
um and he had this he read this book and
it was called too good to fail and I was
like what's your marketing strategy he
was like that he's like if I just make
the stuff that I have so [__] good
like if I just make it so that even if
one person sees it they will share it
then eventually I'll win and he now runs
a $100 million do company and so like
and we were roommates back then and so I
I I very much have taken that
perspective like if you're brand new you
just need to make this stuff as good as
humanely possible and the reality is
that it will still suck but you still
have to have that bar because you'll
look at what you did two years ago be
like oh my God that was dog [__] right
but just like holding nothing back like
the reason I I talk about that a lot is
because somebody who's new holding
nothing back is still like barely
valuable right and so like people still
will consume the stuff see that you're
really good and then still pay you for
help they will like they will pay you
for implementation so just give away the
secrets it does not matter are you are
you happy that you're as famous as you
are now it's it has pros and cons
honestly it has pros and cons what's
what's one what's one biggest con and
what's one biggest Pro biggest Pro is
that we can recruit anyone from anywhere
that's what I want but I don't want any
attention privacy is the cost of Fame
like it's a price um the con is privacy
it just doesn't exist so like every
single time I go out to eat with Ila
I'll have three or four people interrupt
us because it's the one time they're
going to see me and they want to take a
picture they want to tell me about their
business and and like the first two
times it's awesome you know and then
like the 100th time it's like you know
you still want to be really excited
about it because the thing is is like I
also don't want the reputation of like
yeah I met him in person he's a dick and
it's just cuz like it's my 10,000th of
this and it's the first time and the
last time this will ever happened for
you and just trying to and so I think on
some level it actually changes your
behavior because if you basically
realize that everyone is recording you
at all times like mentally or literally
recording you um you just you're like
okay I just can't have bad days sorry do
you guys get that because like you're
obviously done there with like you guys
are big but like do you get recognized
interrupted [__] stuff like that I
choose to Little
Alaska I mean for me it's just been I
mean it's been 10 months since I started
and it's definitely like it's like
surreal at this point like now just like
I'm in college so if I go to like I went
to a college bar I was just like what
the [__] um walking around like yeah
it's it's weird but I feel like it's
that trade-off you have to kind of
accept especially if you I mean in my
head it's just like I want to continue
to grow on social media and then
leverage that to grow my business like I
want to do that that's just yeah it was
a choice I did it on purpose and like it
took me a long time to get there cuz I
was like I really don't know if I want
to do this but it was a choice and the
one thing about it is that it is like a
tattoo is like having a kid it is
irreversible which is why it took a
really long time to like think about
whether I wanted to do it or not so like
if you have a skill and you don't really
particularly care for it then I would
say don't worry about it just go get the
businesses the way you know how to get
them and then just let them funnel the
people into it and do the work that you
know how to do
okay so we covered I think we covered
organic stuff let me see if there's any
other um if you had to assign a value
like a network to your social presence
what's what valuation did you give that
break it's probably worth about a
billion dollars right now honestly like
that's not me exaggerating that's
um just from the amount like if I were
to just quantify what we like the amount
of media that we get and the conversion
value of that media so like if if like
if I had an elegant like the most
elegant conversion system would be like
we go public
and I said hey do you guys want to
invest in this I've taken this thing
from here to 250 million a year I think
a lot of my audience would be like yeah
in and then that would immediately
acquisition knom would be a
multi-billion dollar company